look at this one it's 23 years
three-year-old Willow and she fell in
love with 62 year old David he said I'm
freaking Tinder she
inder
sponsorships
62. I'm gonna I'll give it to him I mean
he doesn't look 62. dude this dude got
his PhD for sure
that Belfast date was
after they became boyfriend and
girlfriend within an hour I wake up
every morning and
he's like do I have a model in my bed
and I'm like at 6am
getting ready to go to our anniversary
dinner
three months
in Las Vegas twice however the 40-year
age Gap has attracted some online
criticism if you like to call me a gold
digger some people say I'm just a sugar
daddy honestly what y'all think I'm
gonna be dead on us
I'm David I'm a real estate developer
here in Charlotte it's my girlfriend
Willow this is our crib
this is our Penthouse here in Charlotte
Nascar Hall of Fame right down here
Mint Museum right there Convention
Center
I won Afternoon Of The Year there before
you were born perfect we met online on a
dating site and we have been together
you know what the funny thing about her
being on Tinder is and they matched she
had her settings to like 70. oh is that
how that worked yeah there's like age
setting so that means she had it to like
the Max and was like [__] it I like this
guy look people are attracted to what
they're attracted to so if she's
attracted to him that's fine good for
her leave it alone but I can tell you
that I'm far closer in age to him and I
wouldn't go near him with a 10-foot pole
I don't I just I I don't understand the
the thing wow you don't know for older
men I don't I'm not attracted to older
men I can understand the older men
attraction to younger girls I mean that
makes perfect in the opposite but not in
her not in moving from her to him I
don't understand it but I can bet my
life this chick was in high school five
years ago yeah like she's still young
enough to have her prom picture on her
nightstand so and she's with him but
okay so I would bet my life okay yeah
sure she's into him but if he wasn't a
real estate developer that had all this
money and that amazing Penthouse
apartment and bopped her all over the
world for fun luxury vacations if he was
the guy that delivered her Pizza she
would not be in a relationship with him
well obviously but that's like I don't
know I don't know how I feel about that
argument because if you're a pizza boy
you don't realistically have a lot of
you don't have a lot of Ambitions bro
you're not an entrepreneur you're not
you're not making your own money you're
a pizza boy like that's like his
personality right that's like the most
NPC job anybody can go around being a
pizza boy like not [__] on it okay
all right I got you but it's like no no
[__] like who the hell would want to be
with an older pizza boy or even like
would you rather be with a young or
successful guy that has a lot of life
experience has a good Network like I
don't know yeah you know you're right
you're right okay you're making yeah so
my argument is void that's fine either
way I don't understand this but it is
what it is and what even if she was with
a 25 year old guy I would still tell her
to put more clothes on when she goes out
in public because she still looks cheap
and there's no need for that I'm sure
she paid a fortune for that dress
probably trying to look hot for the
camera today
stunning now yeah she's beautiful crazy
to see gorgeous he could be her Grandpa
not even the dad
he's like do I have a model in my bed
and I'm like
yeah
yeah he still thinks it's too good to be
true and I'm like I'm just I'm just here
existing my baby just moved in three
days ago it's so funny that like she has
you guys she doesn't have to do [__]
she's just hot and she gets to live this
whole lifestyle as a guy that's not
happening you're not just striking gold
getting to fly to my Bali Dubai sleeping
get your Starbucks absolute Sugar Mama
oh my God no no you have to be willing
to do this you have to be willing to
snuggle up against an old lady like she
is that's even more oh that's even worse
that's way worse than this I mean let's
just be real is it way worse because
well there's multiple reasons the I'm
just looking where to start I'm just
blanking I'm a dumbass what are you
gonna do multiple reasons why well
because no because attraction like
physical attraction to a woman isn't as
important as I mean physical attraction
to a man is more important than physical
attraction with a woman do you see what
I'm like so like if you're like like he
he's a fine looking guy like he's he's
stronger yeah he's older but like dating
like an old old a wrinkly old woman is
way worse than a girl dating an older
guy I
guess it's just my bias maybe I'm just
that's just what I think right you you
would disagree I mean I guess I think
it's equally equally unappealing yeah I
don't know I think it's like but there's
there's something for everybody has
their own I'm not vouching for like old
guys like go grab them I'm just saying I
think it's different like I think her
making the sacrifice to be with an older
guy wouldn't be as bad in the head of a
guy who has to be with an older woman
like that sucks that legit sucks am I
gonna get canceled no it's that's your
opinion I also think that this is yucky
and I can acknowledge that he's a good
looking man I think it's yucky I
wouldn't even go out with them so I
don't understand it so you're not
attracted to older women I I get that
I'm not attracted to older men we share
that yeah but the majority of women
age-appropriate people the majority of
women to to begin with already like men
that are older than them and more mature
it's just not to like this extent who
says who says that's like calm that's
just a a common thing girls like men who
are stronger than them taller than them
older than them they have more life
experience they can handle their
problems better you don't think so I
don't know I I know some girls who are
like that and some who are like me
they're like they're like everybody in
their General no more than five years
older you know in their same general
area I'm not I'm not saying 20 years
older but older it's also a bigger like
the age discrepancy at my age is a lot
different that sounds like you're just
repeating an entertain talking point
more so than speaking from that's not
even an educate talking point I feel
like that's just the truth maybe I'm
tripping maybe let me know in the
comments if I'm just tweaking right now
I've been trying to figure out how much
in my closet I'm giving up most likely a
bunch This is Gonna Be Mine and this is
gonna be mine and this is gonna be his
when I first met him I didn't ask you
how old you were
said in his bio
really Inspire anything outside I just
wanted to like know him first I was a
little concerned about her age because I
was like you're really young I have a
baby face
on the wall poem
and from there it's been constant
constant non-stop for the last 90 days
this is her favorite place I'll tell you
all these all all of this guy's friends
couldn't be more jealous I'll tell you
that for sure all of them with their old
wives and they're seeing him with this
thing
get out of town kid they're all oh I'm
sure pissed something to talk about in
every house and you know all the friends
houses the wives are like what's up with
[__] Joe with that young girl what's
wrong with him he's so immature yeah and
all the husbands are like yeah totally I
can't I would never do that
my ass I
I you know you're absolutely right I
hope that this works out for them but
he's just started to say the past 90
days okay so then for 90 days she's
moving in that is crazy I hope it works
out okay to the conversation earlier if
the roles were reversed and then the
family's friends were talking about it
would the wives ever be jealous that her
older you know her friend that's her age
is dating a 23 year old man would the
wives ever be like oh she's so lucky yes
don't ask me why I'm not getting into it
okay I'm like the answer is yes all
right let's leave that there then all
right no I'm I was asking you but hell
yes
oh I don't even have to hurry no he does
not that's Haram though he acts like a
15 year old boy
I get B12 energy shots
for real yeah
oh literally it's not fast
we've been in the Bahamas like three
times in Punta Cana in Las Vegas twice
in West Virginia twice or three times
it took me to see the Backstreet Boys
see the other thing about this
documentary is they're also like I don't
know how much they they cut and how much
they interviewed them they're really
only talking about the stuff he's taking
her to do so it makes her seem like a
gold digger even more I don't think
she's coming off as a gold digger she
actually seems like a nice girl but like
like am I it's not like he's just giving
her like I mean I don't know but it
doesn't seem like he's just giving her
money to hang out and he's like all
right baby like you stick with me 10
years you good half my [__] when I die
it doesn't seem like that just seems
like it's just dating I don't know no
and what I said earlier about how she
wouldn't even you know give him a look
if he didn't have money you're the point
you made to counter that was was really
strong and valid but at the same time
would she have even given him a look and
said he's attractive you know because
I've had you could have somebody deliver
pizza not that you want to hang out with
them but you could look at them be like
damn that's a good looking pizza guy
would she have even noticed him and and
well she swiped on him it's not like
he's like pictures he's a good looking
guy I I can't wrap my head around being
attracted to somebody like this yes but
I that much older it's just so skeevy to
me the thought of her being intimate
with him just grosses me out but it's
not my business that's their business
and if they're into it then wish them
luck coming up I was like three four
five like listening to the Backstreet
Boys and I wasn't old enough to go to
the concert in public people never
really say anything at all but on social
media
the guys give him a nod and people say
I'm just a sugar daddy oh they're so
cute with your dad
Vegas with your grandpa and what you're
doing is sick I'm not allowed to read
comments anymore because I take stuff
personally so I'm like
uh look at this person's being made to
everyone
the haters and that's how we live by it
people keeps saying
I was influenced a lot by Rihanna in my
teen years so I have a mentality
my family has been really really
supportive of our whole relationship and
her mother's like I'm convinced you all
knew each other in a prior life
listen really she's I've never seen my
daughter smile and be this happy I tell
all my friends it's weight I see don't I
said do not give me any crap watch your
hand
how are you
yeah you're good what do you think about
like what do you think about that from
like her parents perspective being with
the secure older guy like yeah he's
older but like what are you what are
your thoughts on that would you want her
to be with the younger guy I mean yeah
probably you know you would yeah I'll
tell you why but first like well like if
I'm your daughter and I'm doing this
what are you telling me I'm telling you
okay he's 62 in 10 to 15 years you're
going to be in your Prime and you're
going to be wiping his ass and cleaning
his Dentures for him you know most
likely or he's only gonna be 70 then but
yeah 75 80. okay it's not that happens
in a blip if you're lucky and you have
kids now you're raising those on your
own you're raising these kids on your
own unless you have them like now any
right and even still you know those kids
are going to say have say goodbye to
their father which could happen in with
a young Dad too but I mean I have
friends who have who like that's yeah
yeah but it's just it's just not an
ideal situation I don't think and a man
an older person comes with
ex-husbands sex-wives other grown
children baggage maybe grandchild
history I mean there's there's something
that as a mother I would want for truly
a fresh start from my child and I would
want them to be embarking on life
together with somebody yeah yeah you
know you know what I think is yeah and
but those are
the criticisms you know what I think is
the especially weird thing about this is
that if he has kids they're older than
the girl he's dating yeah most likely
that's what I think is kind of weird
like just in my head that would be like
even if we had a kid at 40 or 30 39. it
would be the same age as her that's
something you look beautiful as always
too thank you
we're celebrating the big three months
three months of something there you go
you remember our trip to tuna brought my
beautiful model my little Willow and uh
you know I was a little nervous bringing
her out you know bringing her over to
her parents no I think I mean oh my God
dad's got another thing I didn't even
think of that's gonna be weird when
they're hanging with his friends and
it's all like old people when they're
having like people over it's either all
young kids that are seniors in college
or retirement only right I would like to
think that this girl Willow is old for
her age and mature for her age and can
have conversations with people above the
above the level of a normal 23 year old
honestly what y'all think I mean there's
a big age difference
but who cares nowadays you know if you
guys love each other and you're happy
together then
I'll you know go for it I'm gonna be
dead honest when I saw her with you I
thought she's way too pretty for you how
did you man
you're just as sweet then as as you are
now so no I mean you are you're a
genuine person
I'm born February 2nd she's February 3rd
and her favorite number is like 20
23rd so there's a lot of and we
constantly see two three everywhere it's
crazy I mean you are gonna come to the
wedding right if that were to happen
where would it be y'all want to do it
here it's a private jet to take everyone
in Italy
you already told me that to a
long-lasting relationship for you guys
half the chick ever told me we're gonna
get our private jet to Italy and then
looked at me like that get the [__] out
of here oh you're so you you act like
you're so immune to girls like in there
no she looked like that charm yeah if
she looked like that and she's telling
you that she loves you 20. get a dress
today take out the loan you get your
every whim I don't think this guy needs
a loan for a jet no I know
he doesn't
damn
but three months in to be talking about
getting married is crazy too I mean I
guess you don't have [__] time to
waste
you're gonna do it do it now she's like
I have six more marriages after this one
to take care of we want a dog
nah bro
originally dated older men before
they've learned already and you don't
have to babysit them you're courteous
cannot take care of a lady they open the
car door pull the chair out stand up
when you get to the table and it's nice
we're getting ready to go to our
anniversary dinner have a little
anniversary gift bam we have the private
wine cellar tonight
that means
[Music]
life really as easy as a hot girl my God
I just wish she wore a little more
clothing because I think she could look
so classy on top of how stunning she is
always I don't think anybody else
anybody watching is complaining no one's
complaining like going to McDonald's
happy anniversary to us happy
anniversary
[Music]
talk about the ick like we've seen
you've seen the ick before that's the
ick right there I got the ick and I'm
not even into dudes yeah
oh my God
all right so he is buying her [__]
buying his girl stuff
but it's like they go with your diamond
necklace
necklace yeah look at that oh diamonds
are ghostbusters that treat her like a
queen a polar chair out I stand up when
she stands up you did not pull my chair
out today well didn't the manager or
somebody I mean no
okay
what do you do in that like your chair
is already like pulled out for you like
it was there do I still go around and
then push it in for her yes okay good to
know we'll do it's my life you don't sit
until she's beautiful girl situated
I'm never gonna let down and spend the
rest of my life
she is old enough to drink yeah I am
I even brought her passport just in case
any pretty girls before but it wasn't a
connection this was a connection
a real connection and
she makes me happy so
what am I gonna do
love me love you feed you take care of
you
love don't judge I'm not judging buddy
I'm jealous
[Music]